hello and welcome to this session on
data science with python so what are we
going to do in this session
we will talk about what is data science
and some of the basics
of python as you may be aware data
science
we use either python or r as some of the
tools and programming languages so this
session
the focus is on python so we will talk
about the basics of python
why to learn python how to install
python and then we will
talk about some of the important
libraries which are required for
data analysis and then we will go into a
little bit of details about
exploratory data analysis and we will
take an example there
of uh loan prediction and we will
see a little bit about data wrangling
using
pandas which is one of the libraries of
python and then we will end up with
small
predictive model or logistic regression
model which is
a part of machine learning and in case
you need
more details about machine learning in
this
session we will probably not go into the
details of machine learning there is a
separate session
you might want to look at there is a
separate video on machine learning you
might want to take a look at that if you
need more details here we are just
giving a quick
overview to see how we can use the
scikit-learn library so we will not
go into a lot of details about the
basics of machine learning all right so
with that let's
move forward so what is data science
data science is about
finding insights from the data so
if there is a lot of data if you have
sufficient data how to analyze
and find some insights out of it this is
what is
data science all about a couple of
examples here customer
prediction now let's say you have a
customer base
and you want to find out who are most
likely to buy your product so
you can use from your past behavior you
can probably
develop a model and try to predict who
are the people out of the
thousand leads or potential customers
who will actually buy so there may be
some patterns that you can use to
predict similarly
service planning so for example you're
running a restaurant
and you want to know how many people
will be coming or how many customers
will be
visiting your restaurant on a given day
now based on your historical data you
can
build a model to predict that as well so
that there is no wastage of food and so
on and so forth so
these are very quick and easy examples
of how data science can be used in
business now let's uh talk about python
for doing data science we need some kind
of a programming language or a tool
and so on so this session will be about
python there are other tools like for
example
r and we will probably do a separate
video on that but this session is on
python
and you must have already heard python
is really becoming very popular
everybody is talking about python not
only data science in iot
and ai and many other places so it's a
very
popular it's getting very popular so if
you are not yet familiar
with python this may be a good time to
get started with it so
why do we want to use python so
basically python
is used as a programming language
because it is
for data science because it has some
rich tools
from a mathematics and from a
statistical perspective
it has some rich tools so that is one of
the reasons why we use
python and if you see some of the trends
if you're probably
tracking some of the trends you will see
that over the last few years python has
become
programming language of choice and
especially for data science sas
was earlier one of the most popular
tools but now
increasingly python is being used for
doing data science and of course
as well as r one of the reasons of
course is that python and r
are open source compared to sas which is
a commercial product so
that could definitely be one explanation
but beyond that i think it is the ease
of
understanding this language the use of
using this language which is also making
it very popular in addition to the
availability of fantastic
libraries for performing data science
what are the other factors
there are speed then there are
availability of number of packages
and then of course the design code all
right so
what are each of these design goal
primarily the syntax rules in python
are relatively intuitive and easy to
understand thereby it helps in building
applications with the con size and
readable
code base so with the few lines of code
you can really achieve a lot of stuff
and then there are a lot of packages
that are available that have been
developed by
other people which can be reused so we
don't have to reinvent the wheel
and last but not least the speed so
python is
relatively faster language of course it
is not as fast as
let's say crc plus plus but then
relatively it is still faster so these
are the three factors which may python
the programming language of choice so if
you want to get started
with python first thing obviously is to
install python
so there is some documentation there are
some steps that you need to follow so we
will try to
briefly touch upon that otherwise of
course there is a lot of material
available on how to install python and
so on you can always look around but
this is one of the game there are
different ways in which you can also
install python so we will
use the anaconda path there is a
packaging tool called anaconda so we
will
use that path you can also directly
install python but in our session we
will
use the anaconda route so the first
thing you need to do is download
anaconda
and this is the path for that and once
you click on this you will come to
a page somewhat like this and download
you can do the corresponding download
based on whether you have a windows
or ubuntu there is a also a download
possible for our package available for
ubuntu if you are doing something on
ubuntu so
based on which operating system in fact
this page will automatically detect
which operating system you are having
and it will
actually suggest so for example you see
here if you are running mac os
then it will automatically detect that
you have max and the corresponding
installers will be displayed here
similarly if you are on some flavor of
linux like ubuntu
or any other then you will get the
corresponding download links here and
then beyond that you can also select
which version of python
you want to install of course the latest
version is
in the three point x range at the time
of recording this 3.6 is
one of the latest versions but some of
you may want to do
or start with the earlier version which
is python 2.7
to point x and you can download that as
well
if you don't have anything installed
then my suggestion
is start with python 3.6 all right so
once you do that you will be able to
install
python and you will be able to run
jupyter notebook
okay so now that you know how to install
python
and if you have installed python let's
take a look at what are the various
libraries that are available
so python is a very easy language to
learn
and there are some basic stuff that you
can do for example
adding or printing a hello world
statement and so on without importing
any
specific libraries but if you want to
perform data analysis
you need to include or import some
specific
libraries so we are going to talk about
those as we move forward so
pandas for example is used for
structured data operations so if you
let's say
are performing something on a csv file
you import a csv file create a data
frame
and then you can do a lot of stuffs like
data munching and data preparation
before you do any other stuff like for
example machine learning or so on
so that's pandas scipy as the name
suggests it is kind of it provides more
scientific
capabilities like for example it has
linear algebra
it has fourier transform and so on and
so forth then you have numpy which is a
very powerful
library for performing n-dimensional
or creating n-dimensional arrays and it
also has some of the stuff that is there
in sci-fi like for example linear
algebra and fourier transform and so on
and so forth then you have
matplotlib which is primarily for
visualization purpose
it has again very powerful features for
visualizing your data for doing the
initial what is known as
exploratory data analysis for doing
univariate analysis bivariate analysis
so this is
extremely useful for visualizing the
data and then
scikit-learn is used for performing all
the machine learning activities if you
want to do anything like
linear regression classification or any
of this stuff then the scikit-learn
library will be
extremely helpful let's talk in little
bit more detail about each of these
libraries so sci-fi as the name suggests
is a scientific
library and it very specifically it has
some special functions
for integration and for ordinary
differential equations so as you can see
these are mathematical
operations or mathematical functions so
these are readily available
in this library and it has linear
algebra modules
and it is built on top of numpy so we
will see what is there in numpy so this
is a
again as the name suggests that num
comes from numbers so it is a
mathematical
library and one of its key features is
availability
of a n-dimensional array object that is
a very powerful
object and we will see how to use this
and then of course you can create
other let's say objects and so on and it
has
tools for integrating with c c plus plus
and also for run code
and then it of course also has linear
algebra and fourier transformation and
so on
all these scientific capabilities okay
what else pandas is another very
powerful
library primarily for data manipulation
so if you're importing any files you
will
want to create it like a table so you
will create what is known as
data frames these are very powerful data
structures that are used in python
programming so pandas library provides
uh this capability and once you import a
data import the data into data frame you
can pretty much
do whatever you're doing like in a
regular database so people who are
coming from
a database background or sql background
would really like this because it is
very
they will feel very much at home because
it feels like you're
using you're viewing a table or using a
table
and you can do a lot of stuff using the
pandas library now there are two
important terms or components in pandas
series and the data frame i was just
talking about the data frame so
let's take a look at what are series and
what is
a data frame so within pandas we have
series and data frames so series is
primarily some of you may also be
knowing this as
let's say an array so it's a
one-dimensional structure data structure
if you will
so in some other languages we may call
it as an array or
maybe some others probably an equivalent
of a list
in r perhaps i'm not very sure on that
aspect but yes so this is like a
one-dimensional
storage of information so that is what
is series whereas data frame
is like a table so you have a
two-dimensional structure
you have rows and you have columns and
this is very people
as i said who are familiar with sql and
databases will be able to relate to this
very quickly so you have like a table
you have rows and columns and then you
can manipulate the data
so if you want to create a series this
is how you would create a code snippet
and as you can see the
programming in python is very simple
there are no
major overheads you just need to import
some
libraries which are essential and then
start creating objects so you don't have
to do
additional declaration of variables and
things like that so that is i think
one key difference between python and
other programming languages and
what does this series contain it has to
contain these numbers 6
3 4 6 and x is my object consisting of
the series so
if you display if you just say x it will
display the contents of
x and you will see here that it creates
a default index then you have data
frames so if you want to create a data
frame
as you can see the series is like a
one-dimensional structure there is just
like a
row one row of items whereas a data
frame
looks somewhat like this it is a two
dimensional structure so you have
columns in one dimension
and then you have rows in the other
dimension how do you create a data frame
you
need to create you need to rather import
pandas
and then you import in this case we are
basically
creating our own data so that's the
reason we are importing
numpy which is one of the libraries we
just referred to a little bit
before so we are using one of the
functionalities within numpy to create
some random numbers otherwise this is
not really mandatory you probably will
be importing the data from
outside maybe some csv file and import
into the
data frame so that's what we are doing
here so in this case we are creating our
own test data that's the reason we are
importing numpy as np
and then i create a data frame saying pd
dot data frame so this is the
keyword here similarly here in this case
while creating series we said pd
pd.series
and then you pass the values similarly
here using pd.data frame now in order to
create the data frame it needs the
values in each of these cells what are
the values in the rows and what are the
values in the
column so that in our example we are
providing
using this random number generator so np
dot random
is like a class or a method that is
available in numpy
and then you are saying okay generate
some random numbers
in the form of a four by three matrix or
4 by 3 data frame
the 4 here indicates the number of rows
and
the 3 here indicates the number of
columns so these are the columns 0
1 2 other columns and these are the rows
here 0
this is 1 this is 2 this is 3 okay
and once again it will when you display
df
it will give us a default index there
are ways to
omit that but at this point we will just
keep it simple so it will
display the default index and then the
actual values in each of these rows and
columns so this is the way you create a
data frame so
now that we have learned some of the
basics of pandas let's take a quick look
at how we use this in real life so let's
assume we have a situation
where we have some customer data and we
want to
kind of predict whether a customer's
loan will be approved or not so we have
some historical data
about the loans and about the customers
and using that we will try to come up
with a way to
maybe predict whether loan will be
approved or not so let's see how we can
do that so this is
a part of exploratory analysis so we
will first start with exploratory
analysis we will try to
see how the data is looking so what kind
of data so
we will of course i'll take you into the
jupiter notebook
and give you a quick live demo but
before that let's quickly
walk through some of the pieces of this
program and
slides and then i will take you actually
into the
actual code and do a demo of that so the
python program structure looks somewhat
like this
the first step is to import your all the
required
libraries now of course it is not
necessary that you have to
import all your libraries right at the
top of the code but it is a good
practice so
if you know you are going to need a
certain set of libraries
it may be a good idea to put from a
readability perspective it's a good
practice to put
all the libraries that you're importing
at the beginning of your code
however it is not mandatory so in the
middle of the code somewhere if you
feel that you need a particular library
you can import that library and then
start using it in the middle of the code
so that's also perfectly fine it will
not give any errors or anything however
as i said it's not such a
good practice so we will import all the
required libraries in this case we are
importing
pandas numpy and matplotlib and in
addition
if we include this piece of code
percentage matplotlib inline
what will happen is all the graphs that
we are going to create the
visualizations that we are going to
create
will be displayed within the notebook so
if you want to have
that kind of a provision you need to
have this
line so it's always a good idea when
you're starting off i think it's a good
idea to just
include this line so that your graphs
are shown
in line okay so these are the four we
will start with these four
lines of code then the next step is to
import your data so in our
case there is a training data for loans
by the name
loan p underscore train dot csv and
we are reading this data so in this case
you see here
unlike the previous example where we
created a data frame with some
data that we created ourselves here we
are actually creating a data frame
using some external data and it's the
method is very very straightforward so
you use
the read underscore csv method and it is
a very intuitive
function name and you say pd dot read
underscore csv
and give the path of the file csv file
that's about it and then
that is read into the data frame df this
can be any name we are calling it df you
can call xyz
anything this is a name just name of the
object so head
is one of the methods within the data
frame and
it will give us the first five so this
is just to
take a quick look now you have imported
the data you want to
initially have a quick look how your
data is looking what are the values in
some of the columns and so on and so
forth right so
typically you would do a head df dot
head to get
the sample of let's say the first few
lines
of your data so that's what has happened
here so it displays the first few lines
and then you can see what are the
columns within that
and what are the values in each of these
cells and so on and so forth
you can also typically you would like to
see if there are any null values or are
there any is the data
for whatever reason is invalid or
looking dirty for whatever reason some
unnecessary character so this will give
a quick
view of that so in this case pretty much
everything looks okay
then the next step is to understand the
data a little bit
overall for each of the columns what is
the
information so the describe function
will basically give us a summary of the
data what else can we do
pandas also allows us to visualize the
data and this is more like a part of
what we call it as univariate analysis
that means each and every column you can
take and
do some plots and visualization to
understand
data in each of the columns so for
example here the loan amount column we
can take and then
the hist basically hist method will
create a histogram so you take all the
values from one column which is loan
amount
and you create a histogram to see how
the data is distributed right so that's
what is
happening here and as you can see there
are some extreme values so this is again
to
identify do we have to do some data
preparation because
if the data is in a completely hazard
way the analysis
may be difficult so these are the
initial or exploratory data analysis is
primarily done to understand that
and see if we need to do some data
preparation before we get into the other
steps like machine learning
and statistical modeling and so on so in
this case we will see that here
by plotting this histogram we see that
there are some extreme values so there
are some values a lot of it is around
100 range but there is also something
of one or two observations in the 700
range so
it's pretty scattered in that sense or
they are not really scattered
distributedly scattered but it is
randomly scattered so the range is
really huge so what can we do about this
so there are some steps
that we need to do normalization and so
on so we'll see that in a bit so this is
for
one of the columns let's take another
column which is applicant income
similar kind of similar situation you
have most of your observations in this
range but there are also some which are
far
off from where most of the observations
are so this is also pretty this also has
some extreme values so we'll have to see
what can be done credit history
is the binary value so some people have
a zero
value and some will have credit history
of one this is just like a flag
so this basically is telling us how many
people
have a one and how many people have zero
so looks like majority of them
have a value of one and a few about 100
of them have a value of
0. okay what else can we do so we now
understood a little bit about the data
so we need to do some data wrangling
or data munching and see if we can
some bring in some kind of normalization
of all this data and we will
kind of try to understand what is data
wrangling and
before we actually go into it okay so
data wrangling is nothing but a process
of
cleaning the data if let's say there are
there are multiple things that can
happen
in this particular example there were no
missing values but typically when you
get some data
very often it will so happen that a lot
of
values are missing either there are null
values or there are
a lot of zeros now you cannot use such
data as it is
to perform some let's say predictive
analysis or perform some machine
learning activities and so on so
that is one part of it so you need to
clean the data the other is unifying the
data now
these ranges of this data are very huge
some of them
are going from some columns are going
from 0 to
100 000 and some columns are just
between 10 to 20 and so on
these will affect the accuracy of the
analysis so
we need to do some kind of unifying the
data and so on so
that is what wrangling data wrangling is
all about so before we
actually perform any analysis we need to
bring the data so to some kind of
a shape so that we can perform
additional analysis actual analysis on
this and get some insights
now how do we deal with missing values
is a very common issue when we take
data or when we get data from the
business when a data scientist gets the
data from the business so
we should never assume that all our data
will be clean and all the values filled
up and so on because
in real life very often there will be
the data will be dirty
so data wrangling is the process where
you kind of clean up the data
first of all identify whether the data
is dirty and then clean up so
how do we find some data is missing so
there are
a few ways you can write a small piece
of code which will
identify if for a given column or for a
given row
any of the observations are null
primarily
so this line of code for example is
doing that it is trying to identify
how many null values or missing values
are there for
each of the columns so this is a lambda
function
and what we are saying is find out if a
value is null and then
you add all of them how many
observations are there
where this particular column is null so
it does that for all the column
so here you will see that for loan id
obviously it's an id so
there are no null values or missing
values gender has about 13 observations
where the values are missing
similarly marital status as three and so
on and so forth so we'll see here for
example the loan amount has 21
observations where the values are
missing loan amount term
has 14 observations and so on so we'll
see how to handle this
missing values so there are multiple
ways in which you can
handle missing values if the number of
observations
are very small compared to the total
number of observations then sometimes
one of the easy ways is to completely
remove that
data so or delete that record exclude
that record so that is one way of
doing it so if there are let's say a
million records and
maybe 10 records are having missing
values it may not be
worth doing something to fill up those
values it may be better off to
get rid of those observations right so
that is the
missing values are proportionately very
small but if there are
relatively large number of missing
values if you exclude those observations
then
your accuracy may not be that very good
so
the other way of doing it is we can take
a mean value or for a particular column
and
fill up wherever there are missing
values fill up those
observations or cells with the mean
value so that way what happens is
you don't give some value which is too
high or too low
and it somehow fits within the range of
the observations that we are seeing so
this is one technique again
there are it can be case to case and you
may have to take a call based on
your specific situation but these are
some of the common methods if you see in
the previous case
loan amount had 21 now we went ahead and
filled all of those with the mean
value so now there are zero with missing
values
okay so this is one part of a data
wrangling activity
what else you can do you can also check
what are the types of the data so df dot
d
types will give us what are the various
data types so all right
so you can also perform some basic
mathematical observations
we have already seen that mean we found
out so similarly
if you do call the mean method for the
data frame
object it will actually perform or
display or calculate the mean for pretty
much all the numerical
columns that are available in this right
so for example here applicant
income co applicant income and all these
are numerical values so it will
display the mean values of all of those
now another thing that you can do is you
can actually
also combine data frames so let's say
you
import data from one csv file into one
data frame and another csv file into
another data frame
and then you want to merge these because
you want to do an analysis on the entire
data okay
one example could be that you have data
in the form of csv files one csv
file for each month of the year january
february march each of these are in a
different so
you can import them into let's say 12
data frames
and then you can merge them together as
a single data frame
and then you perform your analysis on
the entire data frame or the
entire data for the year so that is one
example so how do we do that this is how
we do
again in this case we are not importing
any data we are just creating some
random values or using some random
values so let's assume i have a data
frame
which is by the name 1 and i assign
some random values here which is a five
by four format so there are five rows
and four columns
and this is how my data frame one looks
and then i create another data frame
which is data frame two again
random numbers of the format five by
four and i have something like this
now i want to combine these two how do i
combine these two
i can use the concatenate or concat
method
and i can combine these two so pd dot
concat and it takes the
data frames one and two if you have more
of them you can provide them
and it will just simply add all of them
merge all of them or concatenate
whatever you call whichever term you
call
it will so of course we have to make
sure that the structure remains the
same like i said this could be let's say
sales data coming for 12 different
months but each of the files has the
same structure so now you can combine
all of them merge all of them by using
the concat
method if we have let's say structure is
not identical
then what will happen let's say we have
these two data frames
one has a column by the name key and the
second column is as well
and a second data frame which has a
column by the name key but the second
column by the name
are well not l val so you see here the
structure is not identical
so you can still combine them but then
the way they get combined or merged is
somewhat
like this so it takes the key as a
common parameter between them some
common column has to be there otherwise
this will not work
and then we have to use merge instead of
concatenate and when we do a merge then
we get the result will be in this format
what it does is it uses the key
as a common thread between them and then
it kind of populates the values
accordingly so if you see here
the first one had fu and bar for key
and then it had l values of one and two
right so if we go back
foo and bar had one and two l values so
that's what we see here
one and two whereas in the right data
frame
we had foo bar and bar as a second time
and then our values are 3 4 and 5. so
what it has done
for foo it has put for the existing
right for 4 is already existing because
it has come from
left so it will just put the value of r
while here which is 3
similarly it will put 4 here because for
bar if you go back
for bar it is the value is 4 and since
it has one more value of
bar it will go and add this 5 as well
the only thing here is that this one had
for example left had only two values
and only one value for bar but since we
are appending or merging
and there are two key values with the
bar therefore it will
kind of repeat the value of l val here
so that's what we are seeing
in this case right so l value appears
twice
the number 2 appears twice but that is
because r value there are two of them
okay
all right so that is how when you don't
have identical
structure that's how you merge now we
will
talk a little bit about scikit-learn so
scikit-learn is a library
which is used for doing machine learning
of for performing
machine learning activities so if you
want to do linear regression
logistic regression and so on there are
easily
usable apis that you can call and
that's the advantage of scikit-learn and
it provides a bunch of algorithms so i
think that is the good part about this
library so if you want to use
scikit-learn obviously you need to
import
these modules and also there are some
sub-modules
you may have to import based on what
you're trying to use like for example
if we know if we want to use logistic
regression again people who are
probably not very familiar with machine
learning there is a separate module for
machine learning you may want to take a
look at that
but we will just touch upon the basics
here so machine learning has some
algorithms like linear regression
logistic regression
and random forest classification and so
on so that is what we are talking about
here so those algorithms are available
and when if you want to use some of them
you need to import them and
from the scikit-learn library so
scikit-learn
is the top-level library which is
basically sklearn right and then it has
a kind of subparts in it you need to
import those
based on what exactly you will be or
which algorithm you will be using so
let's take an example
as we move and we will see that whenever
we perform
some machine learning activity those of
you who are familiar with machine
learning will already
know this we split our labeled
data into two parts training and test
now there are multiple ways of splitting
this data how do we
either some people do it like 50 50 some
people do it 80 20
which is training is 80 and test it is
20
and so on so it is individual preference
there are no hard and fast rules
by and large we have seen that training
data set is larger than the test data
set and again we will probably not go
into details of why do we do this
at this point but that's one of the
steps in
machine learning so scikit learn offers
a readily available
method to do this which is strain test
split all right so
in this example let's say we are taking
the values x and y
are our values x is the independent
variables and y is our dependent
variable
okay and we are using these two and then
i want to split this into train and test
data
so what do we do we import the train
test split
sub module from within scikit learn
which is sk learn right so within that
we import drain test split
and then you call the strain test split
method or function or whatever you call
it and pass the data
so x is the all the values of the
independent variables
and y is our labels so you pass x and y
and then you specify what should be your
size of the test data so only one you
need to specify
so if you say test size is 0.25 it is
understood that train size will be 0.75
so you're telling
what should be the ratio of the split so
technically it doesn't
nothing prevents you from giving
whatever you like here so
you can give test as 80 and train as 20
so whichever way but then
this normal practices you will have the
training data set would be larger than
the test data set and
typically it would be 80 20 75 25
or 65 35 something like that right so
that is the second parameter and
this is just to say that you know the
data has to be randomly split so it
shouldn't be like you take the first
75 percent and put it in training and
then the next 25 percent and put it in
test so that so such a thing shouldn't
happen
so we first set the state random state
so that the
the splitting is done in a very random
way so they randomly picked up
the data and then put it into training
and test and then this results
in these four data frames so x train
and x test and white rain and white test
okay so that is basically the result it
will
now that the splitting is done let's see
how to
implement or execute logistic regression
so in
logistic regression what we try to do is
try to develop a model
which will classify the data logistic
regression
is an algorithm for supervised learning
for performing
classification so logistic regression is
for classification
and usually it is binary classification
so binary classification means there are
two classes so either like a yes no or
for example customer will buy or will
not buy so that is a binary
classification so that's where we use
logistic regression so let's take a look
at the code how to implement something
like that
using scikit learn so the first thing is
to import this logitech regression
sub module or subclass whatever you call
it and then create an instance of that
so our
object is classifier so we are creating
an object by the name this is the name
by the way you can give any name
in our case we are saying classifier we
say classifier is equal to
logistic regression so we are creating
an instance of the logistic
regression variable or class or whatever
okay
and you can pass a variable or a
parameter rather which is the random
state is equal to 0
and once you create the object which in
our case is named classifier you can
then train the object by calling the
method
fit so this is important to note we
don't call any there is no method like
train here but we call
what is known as there is a method
called fit so you are
basically by calling the fit method you
are training
this model and in order to train the
model you need to pass the
training data set so x underscore train
is your
independent variables the set of
independent variables and y underscore
train
is your dependent variable or the label
so you pass both of these
and call the fit function or fit method
which will actually result in the
training of this model
classifier now this is basically showing
what are the possible parameters that
can be passed or
initiated when we are calling the
logistic
or the instance of logistic regression
so this is but you can also look up the
help file
if you have installed python so some of
these are very
intuitive but some you may want to take
a look at the details of what exactly
they do all right so moving on once we
train the model by calling fit then the
next step
is to test our model so this is where we
will use the
test data you need to pay attention here
here i am calling so there are two
things one is
in order to test our data we have to
actually
call what is known as the method known
as predict
right so here this is where so the
training is done now is the time for
inference isn't it so we have the model
now we want to check whether our model
is working correctly or not so what do
you do
you have your test data remember we
split it 25
of our data was stored here right we
split it into test and training so that
25 percent of the data we pass
to and call the method predict so that
the model will now predict the values
for
y right so that's why here we are
calling it as y underscore predict and
if we display here as i said this is the
logistic regression which is basically
binary classification so it gives us the
results like yes or no
in this particular case and then you can
so this is what the model has
predicted our model has classified now
but we also know
we already have the labels for this so
we need to compare
with the existing labels with the known
labels
whether this classification is correct
or not so that is where
is the next step which is basically
calculating the accuracy and so on will
come into play okay
so in this case the first thing most
important thing to note is
we do the prediction using predict and
here we are passing x underscore test
and not
train right in this case we did x and
divided so again
one more point to be noted here in case
of training we will pass
both the independent variables and also
the
dependent variables because the system
has to internally it has to verify
that is what is the training process so
what it will do it will take the x
values
it will try to come up with the y value
and compare with the actual y value
right so that is what is the training
method so that's why we have to pass
both x as well as y whereas in case of
predict
we don't pass both we only pass because
we are
pretending as if this is the actual data
so in actual data you will not have the
labels
isn't it so we are just passing the
independent variables
and the system will then come up with
the y values which we will then
okay remember we also know the actual
value so we will compare this with the
actual values and we will find out
whether
how accurate the model is so how do we
do that we use
what is known as a confusion matrix so
this is also readily available
in the python library so we import this
confusion matrix and some of you
who already know machine learning will
find this familiar
but those who are new to machine
learning this confusion matrix is
nothing but
this matrix this kind of a matrix which
basically tells how many of them
are correctly predicted and how many of
them are incorrectly predicted so the
some of the characteristics let's
quickly spend some time on this
confusion matrix itself
this the total numbers out here these
are just the numbers
these are like number of observations
then the accuracy
is considered to be highest when the the
numbers
or the sum of the numbers across the
diagonals is
maximum okay and the numbers outside of
the diagonal should be minimum so which
means that
if this model was 100 accurate then the
sum of
these two there would have been only
numbers in these two
along the diagonal this would have been
zero and this would have been zero
okay so that is like a hundred percent
accurate model that is very rare but
just that you are aware so
just to give an idea okay all right so
once you have the confusion matrix you
then
try to calculate the accuracy which is
in a percentage so there are two things
that we can do from a confusion matrix
or that we can calculate from a
confusion matrix one is the accuracy and
the other is the precision
what is the accuracy accuracy is
basically a measure of
how many of the observations have been
correctly predicted
okay so let's say this is a little bit
more detailed
view of the confusion matrix it looks
very similar like as we saw in this case
right so this is a two by two matrix
that's what we are seeing here 18 27
2 1 0 3 so 18 27 2 1 0 3.
now but what are these values that is
what is kind of the labels are shown
here
in this so there are altogether 150
observations so as i said the sum of all
these 4
right 18 plus 27 plus 1 0 3 plus 2
is equal to 150 that's the first thing
we have to observe
the sum of all these values will be
equal to the sum of
test observations number of test
observations we have 150 test
observations
because remember we had about 500 we
split that into
2575 so that is why we have 150 here and
i think 350 in the
training data set okay so that we get
the numbers correct so that's the first
thing
now this next thing is let's take a look
at the actual values
this view is the actual view so there
are
actually right in the actual data we
have labels
yes and no so as per the actual data
there are 45 observations tagged as
no and similarly there are 105
observations
that are tagged as yes or labeled as
yes okay now i know for the first time
when you're seeing this it may be a
little confusing but
just stay with me okay so this is the
actual part of it
and this side tells us the predicted
part of it so
our model is predicted and it has
totally predicted 20 of them as
no right so that is what this says
totally 20 of them it has predicted as
no and it has predicted
130 of them as yes okay i hope this part
is clear so before we go into the middle
part let us first understand
what exactly are these numbers so
actually tagged as no
there are 45 total actually tagged as
yes there are 105
and predicted no there are 20 predicted
as yes there are 130. this is the result
from our model
okay this is the result from our model
and this is the actual value which we
already know because this is our label
data that's the first thing now
now let us take a look at each of these
individually okay
now what are the options we have once
again
okay so now what is happening here let
us look at these
these values so this 18 says that
these are actually tagged as no and the
model is also predicted as
no which means this is what is known as
a true positive right or true negative
sorry
right which means that our model has
predicted is
it correctly it is negative because it
says no
so and it is also predicted no so it is
known as what is
known as true negative okay now let's
come to
this side of it that way we are talking
about the diagonal remember i said
most of the values should be in the
diagonal okay so that means these 18
are correctly tagged they are labeled as
no and our model is predicted as no so
these are
correctly tagged and these are known as
true negative
okay similarly if we come diagonally
down
there are 103 observations which are
labeled as
yes actual value is s and our model is
also predicted as yes
and these are known as true positive
values positive because of this yes
okay right so what is important is this
is true
this is also true so we have to make
sure that
the maximum number of values are in the
true section okay
true positive and true negative that's
the reason i said
the sum along the diagonal should be
maximum now let's see if
our model was 100 accurate this sum
in this case it is only 103 plus 103
plus 18 which is
121 but if our model was
accurate the sum of these two would have
been 150 that means it's a perfect model
okay all right now what else since we
covered these two let's also cover these
two
so here this says that 27 of them were
actually labeled no but our model is
predicted as yes that means this is
wrong right
similarly these are two of them where
the actual value is yes
but our model is predicted as no that
means it's a wrong prediction
you get the point so therefore along the
diagonals
are the correct values whereas in other
places
it is all wrong values or wrong
predictions
okay now how do we calculate accuracy
from this information so the way to
calculate accuracy is so we'd say
okay there are total observations are
150
and what are the correctly predicted
values these are the correctly predicted
values which is
18 plus 103 so this will give us our
accuracy so
103 plus 18 which is 121
divided by our total observations which
is 150
is our accuracy which is 0.8 or we can
say it is 80
okay now there is another concept called
precision so appreciation
is given by the formula true positives
divided by the predicted positives
totally predicted positives okay what do
we mean by that
which are the true positives here
remember which are the true positives we
just recall we just talked in the
previous slide which are the true
positives you see here so this
103 are the true positives which means
that the value is positive
actual value is positive predicted value
is also positive so that's why it's
called a true positive so 103
divided by so that is our true positive
103
divided by totally predicted as yes now
what is totally predicted is yes
remember 130 of them have altogether
been predicted as yes
not that they are correctly predicted
only 103 have been correctly predicted
but 130 of them have been predicted
as yes so precision is basically the
ratio of these two
out of the totally predicted how many of
them are actually true
that ratio so 103 by 130 which is again
about 80 percent
is the precision that's how you
calculate precision so this is just a
simple formula and the term
that you need to remember so accuracy is
you need to take total of
true positive and true negative divided
by the total number of observations
whereas precision is true positives
divided by the totally
predicted positives okay so that is our
accuracy and precision
now what we did the accuracy calculation
was manual
but we can also use some libraries which
are already existing and the functions
within that library so a scikit-learn
provides uh
one such method so for example accuracy
underscore score is one such method so
if you use that
and pass your test and predicted values
only the
y you need to pass right the dependent
variable values
so if you pass that it will calculate it
for you so in this case again
as you can see it still calculates the
same which is 80 percent which we have
seen here as well okay
so this can be done using the method
great so
that's pretty much what we have done
here before we conclude
let me take you into the code and show
you
how it actually looks okay so
this is our code let me run it okay one
by one we've already seen most of the
steps
and slides so i will but i will run this
in the actual
jupyter notebook some of you if you are
not yet familiar with jupiter notebook
again there are other videos we created
on how to install jupyter notebook and
how to
set up jupyter notebook and so on in
this tutorial also we there was one
slide
on how to install python and jupyter
notebook if you have not yet done
please do that so that then you can
actually walk through this
code while you're watching this okay so
what are we doing here
we are importing the libraries required
libraries
recall here we have pandas we have numpy
and
for visualization we have matplotlib
and this line is basically reading the
csv file so we
have the csv file locally on our local
drive
and this is where i'm checking the data
just
so that i'm starting with my exploratory
analysis how the data is looking so it
looks good and no major missing values
or anything like that
so it will display all the columns and
it will
show me the first five rows if when i'm
using this
head function and then i want to see a
kind of a summary of
all the each of the numerical columns so
that's what i'm doing here so these are
the numerical
columns and it gives a summary like how
many observations are there
what is the mean standard deviation
minimum maximum and so on and so forth
for each of them
and then you can do some visualization
so this is the visualization for this
okay the next step is to view the data
data visualization
and we will do that using a histogram
for a couple of these columns so in this
case i'm taking a look at the loan
amount
and if i create a histogram it displays
the data here in the form of a histogram
one thing that we gather from this
as i mentioned in the slides as well as
how the
data is kind of scattered so while most
of the values are in this range 0 to 300
range there are a few
extreme values around the 700 range so
that is one information we get from this
histogram similarly for the applicant
income if we draw a histogram something
similar we can see
that while most of the values are in
this range 0 to 20
000 range there are a few in the range
of 80 000
and probably 65 000 and so on okay
so the next step is to perform data
wrangling where we will
check if any data is missing and how to
fill those missing values and so on so
in this case we will just check for
all the columns how many data or how
many entries are there with missing
values so this is the result so loan id
has all the columns are all the cells
filled gender has 13 missing values
marital status has three missing values
and so on and so forth loan amount has
21 and this is what we are going to show
you how to remove these missing values
so when you have missing values as i
mentioned in the during the slides
there are a couple of ways of handling
that one is you can completely remove
those
or you fill in with some meaningful
values so in this case
we will fill the missing values with the
mean value of the loan amount so let's
go ahead and do that
and now if we check here now
loan amount number of missing values is
0 because what we did was for all these
21
cells where the values were missing we
filled with the mean value of the loan
amount so now there are no more missing
values for loan amount we can do this
for
other columns as well but this was just
one example so we have
shown it here okay so we will
run this for credit history and loan
amount term
as well and then if we calculate
the mean of pretty much all the
numerical
columns that's the method call so
df.mean will give us the mean of all the
numerical values
and another thing that we can do is we
want to find out what are the data types
of each of these columns so you can call
df.d types and get the data types of
course it may not be that very useful
most of the cases is an object but for
example this one it shows as
ind64 and there are float64 and
so on and so forth now in addition to
doing
the exploratory data analysis we can do
some machine learning activity as well
so in this case we are going to do
logistic regression so this is the
example that i have shown you
in the slides as well this is the actual
code for that all right so
the first step here is to import the
libraries
and then the next step is to separate
the independent variables
and the dependent variables so x is our
independent variable
and y is our dependent variable so we
separate the data into
two parts and this will be our target as
well
right so that's how we separate it now
we have to split the data
into training and test data sets as i
mentioned in the
during the slides we use the train test
split method
and when we call this and pass the
independent variables
and the dependent variables and we
specify the test
size to be 0.25 which means the training
size will be
0.75 which is nothing but you split the
data
into training data set which is 75
percent
and test data in which is 25 okay so
once you split that you will have all
your independent
variables data in x train the training
data which is 75 percent of it
similarly independent variables for test
will be in x underscore test and
dependent variable strain will be in
underscore train and dependent variable
test will be y underscore test
once we do this we have to do a small
exercise for scaling remember we had
some data which
was kind of very scattered there were
some extreme values and so on so
this will take care of that so that the
data
is normalized so that before we pass to
our algorithm the data is normalized so
that the performance will be much better
the next step
is to create the instance of logistic
regression
object so that's what we are doing here
so classifier
is our logistic regression instance
right classifier is equal to logistic
regression we are saying so one instance
of logistic regression is created and
then
we call the training method the name of
the method actually is
fit but what it is doing is it is taking
the training data
x is the training data or the
independent variables and y is the
dependent variables so we are taking
both of these
and the model gets trained so the method
for calling
the training is fit okay so it gives us
the output
and then once we are done with the
training we do the
testing and once again just to recall in
the slides when i was showing you the
slides also i mentioned
we don't pass y here while we are
testing while for training we do pass
y but right so for fit we are passing
x and y but for test we are only passing
x
something you need to observe because y
will be
calculated by the model and we will then
compare that with the known value of y
to measure the accuracy so that's what
we will do here
and the method that is called here is
predict
so this will basically create or predict
the values of
y now we have in this case a binary
classification so the outputs are yes or
no y
indicates yes and n indicates no so y or
n
is the output now how do we measure the
accuracy as we have seen earlier i
described how confusion matrix
works and how we can use confusion
matrix for calculating the accuracy
that's what we are
seeing here so this is the confusion
matrix and then you want to do the
measure the accuracy you can directly
use this method
and we find that it is 80 so we in the
slides we have seen when we calculate
manually as well we get an accuracy of
80 okay let's go back to
our slides and uh do
a summary so what we have done in the
session we talked about what is data
science and
why python is being used why it is
becoming so
popular how to install python and we
talked about the various libraries in
python like panda
scipy numpy and so on and then we took a
couple of examples
and wrote the code and demonstrated the
code for performing exploratory analysis
and performing data wrangling
or data manipulation and then we at the
end we did one example of
machine learning using scikit-learn
library
and perform the logistic regression
example
so with that we come to the end of the
session if you have any queries comments
please put them below and you can also
give your email id so that we can get
back to you if you have any questions
i hope you enjoyed the session thank you
very much
[Music]
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel
and click here to watch similar videos
turn it up and get certified
click here